le secteur économique également présents
dans son casier ce matin nous avons avec
nos philippe job bonjour bonjour me
résultant bonjour aux auditeurs de
martinique première est le président de
la chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
la martinique est la grosse surprise de
la rentrée philippe jacq l'énorme souci
pour tout le monde
cette fissure sur la route nationale 9
au niveau de l'échangeur de chateauboeuf
le problème est loin d'être réglé
c'est une catastrophe pour les chefs
d'entreprise de la zone pour l'activité
portuaire
non seulement pour l'activité portuaire
et surtout l'activité économique de la
zone de la jambette et la zac de
rivière-rouge c'est zac et cette zone
industrielle se retrouve complètement
engorgé avec un flux de véhicules
il faut absolument que l'ensemble des
acteurs économiques en liaison avec les
autorités s'étaient m kacem ville de
l'inventaire ville de fort-de-france
trouve des solutions à long terme pour
permettre de fluidifier la circulation
parce que les chiffres d'affaires qui a
été communiqué par les entreprises
depuis la route là les travaux sur la rn
9 sont pour le moins préoccupant est
inquiétant et il faudra remettre sur le
tapis cette fameuse itinéraire bis oui
c'était une réflexion engagée depuis
plusieurs années sur le son appel là le
cd 40 une voie une voie interne les
interzones qui ré de la jambe est
jusqu'à jusqu'à la lézarde en
investissements estimés autour de 40
millions d'euros et qui
aurait aujourd'hui toute sa place et
toute sa justification
début septembre marque la reprise de
l'activité économique la reprise des
colas rentrent aussi pour la formation
les centres de formation des apprentis
on en parle car c'est un des piliers de
la cci philippe giauque c'est un enjeu
majeur pour la martinique quel budget
quelle carte des formations pour quels
publics
le budget du c est fait d'or de 5
millions d'euros 4 millions 8 ans en
2018 avec une carte de formation qui a
été revu et rénové nous avons trente et
une formation à la carte dont huit
nouvelles puisque nous sommes très
intéressés et très préoccupé par
l'adéquation entre les offres de
formation et les besoins des entreprises
les besoins d'aujourd'hui les besoins
dans deux ou trois ans si je le rappelle
le cfa qui a accueilli l'année dernière
près de cinq cent quarante six apprentis
en augmentation de 2% par rapport à la
rentrée précédente avec une une bonne
dynamique ce cfa lance deux nouvelles
formations et nous avons donc je vous
dis huit formations nouvelle qui
commence cette année avec des
partenariats très fort on respecte ce
rapport entre l'offre et la demande
notre préoccupation aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment de former des apprentis qui
seront insérés professionnellement
nous avons aujourd'hui des taux de
réussite aux examens qui vont je
rappelle du crp au bac + 5
calais les formations proposées par la
chambre sont sont de tous niveaux
secteurs du commerce de la vente du
marketing du management de la gestion de
la comptabilité des ressources humaines
mais aussi de l'énergie la logistique et
l'informatique
mais ça veut dire aussi que ces
personnes qui sont diplômés à travers
votre organisme trousses du travail en
martinique
aujourd'hui nous avons un taux
l'inspiration à six mois qui dort de 50%
qui est fort intéressant et nous sommes
en train de mettre en place les outils
de suivi au delà des six mois pour
mesurer cette assertion qui est
essentielle
le message que je peux faire passer
aujourd'hui c'est d'inciter les chefs
d'entreprise à accueillir encore plus
d'apprentis oui c'est le message qu'on
entend depuis un certain temps
l'entreprise parle de formation en
alternance
oui oui si on n'a pas pied dans les eaux
jour d'hui aujourd'hui nous pensons
qu'il faut
le métro au coeur du process les maîtres
d'apprentissage professionnaliser et les
accompagner accompagner les entreprises
dans le choix des apprentis et dans le
process de recrutement les apprentis
pour éviter les échecs et je pense que
nous avons aujourd'hui à tissu
entrepreunarial qui a pris conscience de
la nécessité de métaux nièce le
territoire les jeunes et l'apprentissage
est une voie d'excellence pour la
rentrée
je vous ai parlé de l'échec il faut
lutter contre cet échec à pense qu'il ya
aussi y'a pas que le rapport offre
demande il ya également un autre rapport
malheureusement si les besoins de la
martinique et puis les fantasmes les
envies des uns et des autres dans leur
projet de reconversion
non mais c'est vrai qu'il faut il faut
et je le répète dexia l'occasion il faut
que nous avancions collectivement sur
une gestion prévisionnelle des emplois
et des compétences de telle sorte que
les nos jeunes connaissent les besoins
futurs des entreprises pour que le
projet de vie dans nos choix de
formation il intègre les besoins du
territoire pour ceux qui veulent rester
parce que pascal illusion nous avons une
jeunesse qui est citoyenne du monde
voilà dans cette offre de formation
martinique on doit tenir compte de quels
critères lorsqu'on voit que dans le
catalogue de l'os qui lie à vous il ya
les mfp à il ya le greta il ya les
boîtes privées pour celui qui se dit ben
je vais prendre un nouveau virage à
comment s'y retrouver dans cette jungle
alors vous avez vous avez en matière de
formation certain nombre d'acteurs le
champ et concurrentiel et ouvert ce que
les les jeunes et leurs parents parce
que souvent ils sont accompagnés de
leurs parents ce que les jeunes et les
parents recherchent c'est le taux de
réussite a consenti et l'insertion et
donc le sud sur ce champ là je pense que
les les cfa les chambres consulaires ont
une bonne réputation et ont de bons
résultats qui nous permettent de
continuer à voir des progressions en vie
nous avons eu une grosse malle contient
que ça derrière alors vous vendre à
travers cette argumentation pourquoi pas
mais c'est quand même dans un contexte
bien particulier philippe joker pour
vous en tant que chambre de commerce et
d'industrie puisque vous avez cette épée
de damoclès au-dessus de la tête bruno
le maire -ministre de l'économie annoncé
une baisse de 400 millions des crédits
alloués aux réseaux consulaires de la
france de l'ensemble de la france à
horizon 2022
pour la martinique sa reprise entre et
combien or pour la matinée que ces deux
cent mille euros par année de moins
il faut il faut préciser que outre cette
cette baisse annoncée pour les quatre
prochaines années 200 millions pour le
réseau consulaire
le réseau consulaire a déjà subi une
baisse de 150 millions en 2018 donc sur
la mandature législatives cela
représentera pour la chambre de commerce
incidemment athénée que 5 millions nous
avons aujourd'hui un budget hors
facturations à l'ancienne concession
aéroportuaire dans un budget de 16
millions vous mesurer facilement
l'impact de cette baisse sur sur le
fonctionnement de la scion pas dites moi
il ya des menaces sur l'emploi par
exemple c'est de la chambre alors
l'objectif de l'équipe qui m'accompagne
à la chambre c'est de préserver l'emploi
nous nous ferons tout pour trouver des
ressources alternatives et des
ressources différentes mais il faut
savoir à quoi c'est à cette taxe pour
frais de chambre de commerce
puisqu'aujourd'hui nous l'affectons en
grande partie à l'accompagnement des
entreprises notamment sur le sur les
champs du centre de formalités des
entreprises mais aussi sur la
transmission-reprise la création
développement durable et donc nous
aurons des choix cornéliens a à faire
nous affectons aussi près de deux
millions sur la formation et l'emploi
dont un million 3 pour le centre de
formation des apprentis
donc nous aurons là effectivement des
choix des choix à faire
nous privilégierons autant que faire se
peut mais cela fort dites-nous ce que
veut exactement philippe job dans ce que
nous voulons c'est aujourd'hui que
soient prises en compte par le
gouvernement la la la spécificité des
outre-mer et l'accompagnement que nous
que nous faisons auprès des très petites
entreprises
ça laisse on va vous dire du côté du
ministère de l'économie l'autre maire
veut encore toujours plus il ya toujours
une simplicité à prendre en
considération lorsque je vais rappeler
ces qu'initialement le gouvernement
avait annoncé que 150 millions pour le
réseau consulaire en 2018 c'était pour
solde de tout compte c'était la
contribution des chambres de commerce et
d'industrie au redressement des finances
publiques
donc nous avions imaginé que c'était
compliqué un million quatre de moins
vente unique mais que c'était en une
fois et que nous pouvions
par la suite on prend notre marche en
avant
il faut bien menti on nous allons nous a
le gouvernant a pas respecté ses
engagements sur ce point a menti c'est
très clair oui c'est très clair il y à
des réflexions sur le rôle des chambres
sur le recentrage des chambres sur les
saisons de métier mais là aussi je
l'assistent dans à la fois dans les
territoires ruraux de la france
hexagonale et dans les outre-mer on a
une spécificité qui nous prendre en
compte un tissu de très petites
entreprises et aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
l'attaqué qu'on ferait de chambre elle
est mutualisé et avec eux les grandes
entreprises payent un peu plus que les
petites et ces sommes sont utilisés
essentiellement pour les petites
notamment sur le commerce et d'industrie
de la martinique
nous accompagnons très peu d'entreprises
un petit peu à l'export et pour tout le
reste c'est vraiment le tissu de très
petites entreprises qui l'accompagné
elle serait philippe giauque seul peut
convaincre le gouvernement
il faudra l'appuyer politique il
faudrait l'ami de tout le monde il
faudra faire peuple comme di grassi mal
ça non mais il est évident que que la
chambre de commerce eric martin exion ne
peut pas porter ce dossier
la loi pacte qui va venir en discussion
à l'assemblée c'est l'occasion de
mobiliser nos par nos parlementaires sur
sur la spécificité des chambres de
commerce la nécessité de les accompagner
dans ce rôle essentiel qu'elle joue nous
avons un taux de création d'entreprises
qui est très élevé avant est inique mais
sachez aussi que la plupart grand nombre
de gens créent leur entreprise pour
créer leur emploi donc ça veut dire
quant à moi ils n'ont pas de formation
initialement et n'ont pas de formation
et tout notre boulot à la chambre d
accompagner et nous avons un taux de
mentalité qui est plus faible que la
moyenne nationale précisément parce que
la compagnie d'équipements a présenté
ses arguments et nous sortons les
chiffres et nous les savons déjà que
vous savez lorsqu'il ya une autre
réalité celle des chiffres des économies
qu'on doit faire ce que je peux dire
c'est que à l'occasion des assises d
outre-mer le quai gambetta qui servent à
beaucoup de choses mais on n'a pas raté
j'avais eu l'occasion interpellé le
privé reliques sur cette problématique
spécifique et il va gentiment renvoyé le
le ministre de l'économie à qui j'en ai
parlé qui a demandé à ses services de
voir dans quelle mesure on pouvait
prendre en compte nos particularités
savez je pense d'abord t'aider à mayotte
il ya taux de création d'entreprises qui
est élevé avec de très petites
entreprises
si on supprime les ressources de mayotte
si on baisse des ressources de mayotte
c'est aussi catastrophiques pour
l'europe économique mais dans tout cela
il y aura quand même un made in expo qui
arrivait très très vite ce sera du 4 au
7 octobre alors si cette grande
manifestation qui permet de montrer le
savoir-faire martiniquais vous avez la
tête complètement soit bien vous
répondez aux entreprises qui vous disent
on est pas prêt pour le prélèvement à la
source de la peau alors on s'occupe
aujourd'hui essentiellement de madine
expo c'est vous l'avez rappelé
c'est du 4 du jeudi 4 au dimanche 7
octobre et cette année la particularité
c'est que ma de l'exposer à madiana
parce que nous avons voulu avec l'équipe
de la chambre de commerce lié cette
manifestation qui est la vitrine du
savoir faire industriel martiniquais
avec la conférence de coopération
régionale c'est l'occasion de montrer
l'ouverture des entreprises
martiniquaises à l'international et au
bassin caribéen nous avons les invités
qui viennent de guadeloupe de guyane
mais aussi des pays de l'osce et s est
donc nous sommes dans une dynamique
d'ouverture
savons nous aurons dix acheteurs
internationaux qui viendront pour cette
manifestation et nous avons organisé des
conférences des rencontres b to be avec
les ambassadeurs de france de la zone
caraïbe
merci philippe jobs d'avoir été avec
nous rappelle que vous êtes le président
de la chambre de commerce et d'industrie
de la martinique bonne journée
[Musique]